today on the matt walsh show a left-wing
group puts out the most unintentionally
hilarious political attack ad of all
time hitting ron desantis for not being
a tyrant also there's another alleged
scandal involving christie gnome and
netflix's most popular show right now is
gratuitously violent korean torture porn
what does that tell us if anything plus
youtube moves to ban all anti-vaxx
content but then what is anti-vaxx
content exactly in our daily
cancellation i must cancel dating apps
and i'll explain why all of that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
now a word from a new sponsor on the
show masterworks the global pandemic has
completely disrupted markets and
reckless spending from the president
biden administration is only making
things worse
finding promising places to invest your
hard-earned hundred thousand dollar nest
egg is tougher than ever if you're
anything like me or the rest of america
for that matter it's very difficult um
you're probably heavily allocated
allocated as well into equities which is
exactly what every report from the wall
street journal to city is telling us not
to do and they're
projecting equity returns anywhere from
five percent actually going negative in
the future
with the fed printing trillions of
dollars on congress's monstrous
infrastructure bill it doesn't take a
genius to see
that your money needs a safe haven and
it needs it right now
so how are professional investors
preparing for this nightmare scenario
spoiler they already have they've turned
to an under the radar asset class one
that's historically only been available
to coastal elites and hedge fund
managers it's a real physical asset that
isn't gold or real estate or anything
related to crypto it's actually fine art
and it's one of the oldest and most
stable asset classes of all time and
thanks to a new revolutionary tech
platform you can finally get access to
this exciting
6 trillion dollar world early adopters
have already returned 32 on their
investment and their wait list keeps
getting longer lucky for you they've
given me 60 passes to skip that weight
line to jump to the front of the line
head to masterworks dot io slash walsh
that's masterworks dot io slash walls
previous offers have sold out an hour so
don't wait around before just deciding
to invest carefully review the important
disclosures at masterworks dot io
disclaimer so i was on a plane yesterday
flying from my home state of virginia
back to my old stomping grounds of
tennessee uh it's great to be back here
kind of nostalgic giving a speech i'll
be giving a speech in um in memphis
tonight i'll be at the faith baptist
church bartlett to give the keynote
speech at the confidential care mobile
ministry 25th anniversary banquet doors
open at 7. anyway on the plane on the
way over i had the uh wonderful
experience of being lectured three times
in the first 30 minutes of the flight
for improperly wearing my mask i was
wearing it but improperly and the first
couple lectures it was it was uh you
know i had my nose exposed and you don't
want to have your nose exposed when
you're wearing the mask no one's ever
been able to explain why that's the case
what is it what does it actually matter
to you
if my nose is poking out over the mask
do you think that i'm going to infect
someone who's wearing a mask is probably
vaccinated just by breathing through my
nostrils what's the likelihood of that
but it doesn't matter
at least it doesn't matter to the people
who impose these policies the last
lecture i got
came after i took off my mask to drink
the soda that had just been handed to me
the flight attendant handed me a soda
and i had only taken one sip before she
was back informing me that i can't take
my mask off all the way to drink
a drink so it has to be around my ears
i can pull it down briefly for a sip but
then you have to replace it
that's just science folks okay it's it's
a very dangerous situation if you got to
have the mask even if it's not on your
mouth it's got to be hanging around your
ears and the act of hanging around the
ears affords extra protection
that is pure science right there now she
pretended to be sort of apologetic about
this
um and she explained as they always do
that well this is just the policy sir
it's just the policy
why is it the policy
what sense does it make well those are
irrelevant questions again apparently
now i've done a lot of flying recently i
can tell you that the mask enforcement
on airplanes and in airports tends to
vary
wildly
not from airline to airline but from
flight crew to flight crew these
policies have given power to people
who normally have little power or
authority in their positions
um so it's up to the individuals to
decide how far they'll go with it how
controlling and tyrannical they want to
be
it's just a matter of whether or not
they want to exploit this power so
if they want to decide that you have to
have the mask hanging around your ears
for no reason then they can decide that
even even just like the guy stocking
shelves at the grocery store can yell at
you now if there's a mask mandate in the
store and you aren't wearing yours
properly
um this is ever lots of people have been
given power they didn't have before so
we've learned quite a lot
about our fellow americans through this
time and often unfortunately what we've
learned has not been terribly
encouraging
because there are plenty of people at
every level
in the public sector and the private who
are eager to impose themselves on you
excited to
capitalize on the power they've been
granted however small and limited in
scope it might be
this is not this is not new with covent
by the way this is something we notice
there's a tendency in people you you
you've noticed of course before covet
just the smallest amount of power could
go to someone's head the most tyrannical
person i've ever known or been around
was a a
shift supervisor that i had at a fast
food restaurant where i worked when i
was like 17.
this is a person who had very little
power in his position as shift
supervisor at a fast food restaurant but
he was going to milk that for every drop
that it was worth so we know this about
this tendency in people and i think
covet has really brought that out
and that's why those at the top
who've been granted the most power are
so hesitant to relinquish it principle
among them of course is fauci who this
week has announced that in order to be
fully vaccinated i mean fully fully
vaccinated
you need three shots not two
here's the post-millennial says in in an
exclusive interview with the atlantic uh
joe biden's chief medical advisor dr
anthony fauci revealed that cover 19
booster shots don't keep people alive
but can allegedly prevent severe effects
from the virus according to dr fauci
booster shots add crucial temporary
protection against the virus and will
become a standard regimen in the future
he says quote it's likely for a real
complete regiment that you would need at
least at least a third dose
fauci continued quote i think we should
be preventing people from getting sick
from covet even if they don't wind up in
the hospital uh dr fauci said at the
atlantic festival on tuesday
skeptics of the kova 19 booster shots
believe that boosters won't provide
significant protection and will only act
as a temporary shield to the virus
contrary to the vaccines that were
designed to prevent hospitalization and
death however fauci said that he rejects
skeptics notions and insisted it's
beneficial to have temporary protection
rather than no protection so
some in summary
bad news for the double vaxxed because
you're about to find yourself back in
the ranks of the unvaxed
three shots to be fully vaccinated so
you got two two two two shots and now
you're you're back in the unvaccinated
you're an anti-vaxxer you got two shots
and you're an anti-vaxxer now
three shots will do it that is until it
becomes four shots and five shots and
six shots and so on
as long as they have another shot to
push which they always will because
apparently what they're telling us is
that this and this is not me saying this
youtube this is what they're telling us
apparently that the protection afforded
by the vaccine is very very temporary
or at least the full protection afforded
by the vaccine is temporary which is why
they recommend you get the booster shot
which would mean that there's always
going to be another shot
and as long as there's always going to
be another shot and we can always be
yelling at people who have not gotten
the latest shot the pandemic will
continue
at least they can claim that it's
continuing
and all they need is the claim in order
to have the power
and with all these people from flight
attendants to public health experts to
governors
exploiting their power and clinging to
it like gollum grasping the ring it
becomes even funnier to see how guys
like ron desantis who've declined the
additional powers that the pandemic
panic might have afforded him
are still somehow painted as the
dystopian tyrants
they've declined the power and that
makes them the tyrants
an ad airing in florida right now
put together by a group called remove
ron
tries to make this point explicit but it
only it only succeeds in highlighting
all of the best things about the santas
and also the ad is really just very
funny watch this
ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of your cabin crew we'd like
to inform you that we have officially
entered florida airspeed
now that we're making our final descent
please watch this short message from
governor ron desantis on covet 19.
thereafter everyone on board will be
required to comply with the state's
forever purge
we are not doing any vaccine passports
in the state of florida
we trust people to make their own
decisions in this state we are not going
to be bludgeoning people
with restrictions
and mandates
and lockdowns or any of that stuff
as governor desantis stated
while you're within state lines you do
not have to wear a mask you do not have
to get a vaccine
it is against the law for private
businesses or schools to mandate masks
or vaccines
and you have the absolute right to
infect whoever you want whenever and
wherever with covet 19.
thank you for traveling with us and
please
enjoy your floor ever purge
covet 19 is surging again this is the
time to double down the governor is
doubling down he says students shouldn't
be forced to wear masks if you are
trying to lock people down i'm going to
stand in your way
that's i honestly when i saw that last
night i had to do some digging
because i wasn't i really wasn't sure if
that was actually supposed to be an
attack ad or like some kind of hype
video it was not clear to me
and uh and but oh apparently yes this is
this is we are really supposed to
watch that and come away with it come
away from it with it with a lower
opinion of ron desantis and it only
proves that you actually can't turn
anything sinister just by putting creepy
music in the background
all the creepy music in the world won't
make the phrase we trust people to make
their own decisions suddenly seem evil
or terrified
i mean you could set the jaws theme to
footage of mother teresa walking down
the street or volunteering at a soup
kitchen but it's not going to make
people shake in their boots unless
they're shaking from laughter and this
ad really is unintentionally the most
hilarious political attack out of all
time
it has the exact opposite effect
from the effect that was intended
because i like rhonda santos even more
now i i mean i would love that if i
landed if i was flying into a state and
i landed there and that was the like the
welcome video we watched where they said
hey you'll make your own choices here
you have freedom here
that would be fantastic
what are we supposed to be afraid of
here
what are they attacking him for well
freedom
they're comparing a lack of vaccine
mandates and passports
and his refusal to shut down small
businesses
to a purge where people are running
through the streets murdering each other
at will
they want us to be afraid of freedom
they want us to be afraid of leaders
what few exist who decline to exploit
their authority they want to be afraid
of leaders who value our freedom over
their power
and
to the sane among us we see that and
it's hilarious
then it becomes a little bit less funny
when you realize that for a lot of
americans that message has actually
worked
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i've been telling you about
this new book that if you haven't picked
up yet you really need to pick up what
to say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion
and uh this book you know back when when
they first wrote it and and had the idea
to publish it it was obviously relevant
it's been relevant for for 40 years ever
since roe v wade but they couldn't have
known you know that
this texas bill that abortion would be
back in the headlines right when this
book comes out so there's never been a
better time for it it says it's released
it's already been a number one amazon
new release and a number two amazon
bestseller and it's already on its
second printing
and it's easy to see why that's the case
it's because it's an easy book to use it
tells you what to say what not to say
and the proven arguments
that work with the abortion industry and
have worked for 40 days for life i mean
they've used these arguments they've
been talking to people and they have
actually converted 221 abortion workers
getting them out of the abortion
industry and into a culture of life um
this is an invaluable and timely tool so
you got to get it right now what to say
when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion how to change minds
and convert hearts in a brave new world
go to amazon or get it directly from 40
days for life at 40daysforlife.com yeah
the uh
the
enforcement in the planes
on the with the masking really varies
like i said with with flight crews in
airports too i mean really everywhere
you go in the country and i've done a
lot of traveling recently and throughout
the whole uh
pandemic
and it's always been the case that
it's it's not just city to city but
place to place wherever you go they've
all got their own little version of what
they're doing
um the little measures they've put in
place most of the time don't make any
sense
and so there's no there's just no
coherent
message at all if you didn't know
anything about what was going on with
covet or anything and you just traveled
around to different places and you saw
all of the competing different
conflicting
safety measures that have been put in
place you just have no idea what was
happening you wouldn't have any clue
what they're trying to protect us
against
um and that's especially the case in
airports in fact in reagan airport in dc
that's the first airport i've been to in
many months where they actually enforce
the mass mandate at all i mean usually i
just walk around the airport and i don't
wear the mask
and no one says anything
but i got yelled at two or three times
uh at red reagan airport
because the the people working there are
excited for that
opportunity to yell at you for not
wearing a mask
in fact just just at the bag at the
baggage claim i was dropping my bags off
and as i'm walking away the woman yells
at me where's your mask where's your
mask
i said it's in my pocket well are you
going to put it on yeah sure because i
just walked away and put it on
this has been my
general policy and i've shared with you
before
and i think this is this is really
important and it's something we all need
to start doing if you're not doing it
already
i'm not going to say i can't say
that i simply won't wear the mask at all
because if i say that that means i'm not
getting on planes i'm not traveling to
the places i need to travel to
so i can't say that exactly but what i
will say
is that
this has been my policy all along is i'm
not gonna volunteer to wear the mask i'm
not gonna walk into a place and choose
on my own to put it on
i'm gonna at least make you tell me to
put it on
and then once you depending on who you
are i'll decide if i
care you know if you're just some random
person with no position of authority at
all uh i'm just gonna ignore you i don't
care what you think but if you do have
some position of authority in this
establishment where i am
then i'll decide maybe i want to leave
because i don't want to wear the mask or
i'll put it on but i'm going to make you
tell me i'm not going to volunteer
doing it
um
it it really is
disturbing it's been disturbing for for
to me this this whole time to see
how so many people have just even if
they don't like wearing it they've
gotten used to wearing it and now a lot
of people do like actually like wearing
the mask i noticed this shift in in
planes early on it's like the first
couple of months
when they had the mask mandates and
planes and uh the flight attendants were
prowling through the plane the whole
time telling people put the mask back on
put the mask back on yelling at people
over the the intercom and everything and
you could see people around you they're
always fidgeting with the mask pulling
it down and then this shift happened and
it was pretty sudden from what i
observed a couple months into it where
that people weren't doing that anymore
they just put the mask on over the nose
didn't touch it didn't fidget with it
and kept it on the whole time without
any complaint at all
i i don't
understand that mentality but it's a
pretty disturbing mentality that so many
people have
all right so this is from this is a
report from uh the website american
greatness
and i'll just read the report to you
this is what this is what they are
reporting
we had the we had the the alleged
scandal involving christy gnome
yesterday that we talked about where
allegedly she used her position of
authority to get a position um
for her for her daughter
and you know kind of
nepotism using her influence to get a
position for her daughter that was the
that was the story yesterday we got a
new scandal alleged
this is from american greatness it says
multiple sources have informed american
greatness
that
south dakota governor christinome is
having an extramarital affair with
advisor corey lewandowski who previously
served as a campaign manager for donald
trump the alleged fling reportedly has
continued for months for months sources
say lewandowski accompanied known across
the country as she stumped for trump's
re-election last year according to south
dakota republicans former gnome chief of
staff joshua shields left in part
because the lundowski is butting in
lewandowski was married with four
children still has the former
president's ear which he reportedly uses
to gnome's advantage
american greatness contacted gnome's
office for comment on tuesday no comment
has been received at the time of
publication we do have a comment from
her now which i'll get to a second
uh and gnome is a married mother of
three and has been eyed as a possible
running mate for a trump presidential
bid in 2024 then it goes on to say that
this is uh
allegedly one of those open secrets in
washington dc that everybody knows about
that's the claim anyway
now christy gnome responded to uh these
claims and here's what she said on her
official twitter account her governor
twitter account she said
these rumors are total garbage and a
disgusting lie these old tired attacks
on conservative women are based on a
falsehood that we can't achieve anything
without a man's help i love brian that's
her husband i assume i'm proud of the
god-fearing family we've raised together
uh now i'm getting back to work
all right
here's what i'll say about this uh
i don't know if it's true or not how
could i possibly know that
i i i didn't like the nature of
christina's denial yesterday with the
nepotism scandal
where she said that you will stop
attacking my kids but no one's attacking
your kid that's not the point your kid
who's an adult
they're attacking you and they're saying
that you shouldn't have done this
um and
i also don't really like this denial
because once again
this is like a reflex for her
she did the same thing to me as you
recall
what all i did was criticize her policy
choices
she she reflexively goes to the sexism
charts charge
these old tired attacks on conservative
women i mean come on
give me a break so conservative women
are the only ones who
get accused of sex scandals
it's it's actually
thankfully pretty rare i think for
conservative women that they get
that uh their name gets tossed around
with scandals like this
it's much more common with uh male
politicians
and when it happens the media makes a
big deal of it and it's a it's a story
i mean the public loves sex scandals
they always have it's one of the it's
one of the things that that brings both
sides of the aisle together
so uh
trying to make it into it into a
gendered thing into a sexism thing
that's a lame move
i don't know if that doesn't mean that
it's true
but it's a lame it's a lame form of
denial and meanwhile
as far as the
american public goes
although although
everyone seems to share an interest in
the sex scandal story
we are a bunch of rank hypocrites when
it comes to how we respond to these
sorts of stories
because obviously the the relevance of
an alleged affair
that's going to be judged entirely based
on party affiliation
so this is this is one issue where
almost everybody is a total hypocrite
you know you look at party affiliation
do you like the politician
are they in your party or do you
ideologically align with them and uh if
if you do then then the response is
always well who cares it's their
personal life what does it matter
and if you don't like them then all of a
sudden it becomes it becomes an issue
that's why the left has jumped on this
story
and uh are going after christina about
this pretending pretending now to have
standards on these issues to to value
you know the sanctity of marriage and
everything so that's the way the game is
played
um
i i try not to be a hypocrite on issues
like this as best i
can so i will i will say and i think
i've been pretty consistent on this
uh
i do think that these issues do matter
you know if if a politician has an
affair
it's it's not just their their personal
life
yeah that's that that's not the only
implication here
because it can speak to their integrity
and you have to wonder right if a if
someone is in a position of leadership
position of authority
and they're willing to betray their
family betray someone who they have made
an undying commitment to before god if
they're willing to do that
then you have to ask can i trust them on
anything else
i mean if a politician is willing to
betray their
spouse their family their kids
what what hope do we have in the public
that they're not that they're gonna
what's stay loyal and true and be honest
with us
you you have much less of a of a moral
obligation even as a politician you have
your you have less of a moral obligation
to the public than you do to your family
your first and primary and most
important moral obligation for all of us
is to our own families
and so if we're willing to throw that by
the wayside then it raises questions
about serious questions about integrity
so i do think it matters these kinds of
stories they do matter i don't think we
could just say well it's who cares it's
a personal life
the only question is whether or not it's
true and i have absolutely no idea i
can't possibly know
um but it is a it is a subject worthy of
public discussion
i think
this is also something
when you pursue that position of power
and you get into politics
this is this part of the deal and you
know that going in
if you didn't know it then you should
have
all right next uh so there's this show
on netflix called squid game
that
is apparently right now and netflix is
not very forthcoming with this sort of
information about how many people are
actually watching
their their programs i mean for all we
know you know their top show has like 10
viewers and we would never know because
they don't tell us
but they have told us proudly that this
show squid game is their i think right
now their most popular show across the
world on streaming everybody's watching
this thing
well here's the uh
story from the daily mail dubbing squid
game the most twisted series on tv
it says a gruesome netflix horror series
about a fictional deadly game show in
which poverty-stricken characters
compete battle royale style to win a 27
million dollar cash prize has come under
fire from viewers over its unnecessary
gore and violence
korean-made squid game which is the most
streamed show in the u.s and in the uk
features grisly scenes of characters
being shot in the head in organ
harvesting in the latest example of
shock tactic programming from the
streaming giant
it's become a cult hit with fans i don't
know if you can call it cult hit when
it's the most widely viewed show on
streaming right now
more of a mainstream hit with fans of
the slosh the slasher horror genre who
have dubbed the nine part series saw
meets the hunger games and reveled in
scenes of torture and mass murder
um
but some tv fans have been left repulsed
by the excessive violence with several
saying they could not even make it
through the first episode and others
recommending it be banned for viewers
under 20 because it's too gory
and then it goes into
uh graphic descriptions i probably don't
need to read in each episode of squid
game characters take part in bloody
versions of traditional children's games
like grandmother's footsteps or british
bulldogs with the winners
progressing to the next round of the
game show the loser losers are executed
by a masked death squad standing by with
machine guns
but
i guess
does add some extra intensity to a to a
to jeopardy or to a game show if that's
the way they're doing it
um and then it goes into graphic
descriptions of of what the show uh
depicts and i don't need to get into
that
you know i haven't having having not
watched the show and i don't plan on
watching it
um
it does bring up this conversation about
violence in shows and in windows that go
too far
there's a there's a tendency
um among people i think on both sides
really
to say that uh but we try to say this
about entertainment in general whether
it's sexual content or violent content
and we say it's just entertainment it
doesn't have any effect on anybody come
on
that's silly what so i'm gonna watch
squid game and then go out and uh join a
death squad and start executing people
you think that's what i'm gonna do
people do the same thing with
pornography and this is really like a
form of porn this is this is torture
porn
which seems to be coming back into
popularity i remember when i was uh when
i was a teenager that was a big genre
that things like uh
like like saw uh there's a movie called
hostile and other movies where
that was the whole attraction to the the
film you went you watched people get
tortured for 95 minutes and then you
left and there was really no plot that's
just all that happened
and
it seems like those kinds of shows
dipped in popularity but are now surging
back into popularity so it's a kind of
it's a kind of pornography it's torture
porn
and with actual sexual pornography you
hear the same kind of thing the people
defending it saying i'm not what i'm to
watch poor or anything i'm going to go
out and become a rapist come on that's
ridiculous
yeah when you
if you if you if you want to be
reductive about it
and try to draw these simplistic
dots and connect them that directly then
yeah it seems silly like no one is is
suggesting that you're gonna watch a
show like squid game and then go out and
kill people directly as a result
that would that would be an absurd thing
to suggest but no one's suggesting it
it's just as absurd to suggest that
you're not influenced at all
by the images and messages and ideas
that you sit there passively
eating your doritos and drooling
and
ingesting that is also absurd of course
it has an effect on you
we're human beings we have minds we're
we are affected by all of the messages
and images
that we come in contact with the
advertising industry is ba if we're not
affected by by images and messages and
ideas then the advertising industry
wouldn't exist
and with that with advertisements they
can influence you in 30 seconds
they can influence you with a with a
billboard you see on the highway for
three seconds as you're driving by
that's how
impressionable how easily influenced we
are
and so i do worry about that
with pornography of course and i worry
about that with with
with gratuitous violence in films and in
shows
and when i say gratuitous that doesn't
mean that every single show and movie we
watch has to be rated g you know i don't
i don't think that at all some of my
favorite films of all time saving
private ryan one of my favorite films
extremely violent
i think what makes it gratuitous
is when
almost all of the entertainment value
is in watching people
be mutilated and
and killed in all of these gory and
graphic ways when when that is the
entertainment you know if violence is
part of the story you're watching a war
film
violence is part of the story you can't
take violence out of that you're gonna
take violence out of a of a war story
you might as well not tell the story at
all
but when the whole story is the violence
and the entertainment value isn't
watching people
be ripped open and uh and disemboweled
that's when it becomes gratuitous
and that's when you have to
worry about the kind of influence that
has on us
and i think the primary influence is not
that it's turning people into murderers
uh it's just it's just a it's
desensitization it's moral
desensitization
which is also one of the primary
influences of pornography
it's not that it causes you to go out
and do things kind of the opposite it
just it just
turns you into this sort of blank slate
and you become desensitized to these
kinds of images
and even though it's fictional
right if you're watching someone
be disemboweled in squid game
it's fictional
but if you're sitting there watching it
and enjoying it
you do have to ask yourself why do i
enjoy watching this
even though it's fictional what is it
about this
because part of enjoying a fictional
story when you're watching a show part
of the enjoyment aspect is to forget
that it's fictional if you have in your
mind the whole time oh this is fictional
this is fictional then you can't enjoy
it that's called breaking the fourth
wall right
so you have to surrender your mind to
this story
and get into the mentality sort of
pretend that it's not fictional so then
you have to ask yourself what is it
about that that i enjoy watching
it is feeding a part of me
that probably should not be fed
all right next uh this is from msn it
says youtube is banning prominent uh
this is a headline youtube is banning
prominent anti-vaccine activists and
blocking all anti-vaccine content
all anti-vaccine content is being
blocked by youtube
but what does that mean well let's find
out
it says youtube is taking down
several video channels associated with
high-profile anti-vaccine activists
including joseph mercola and
uh
robert f kennedy jr who experts say are
partially responsible for helping seed
the skepticism that's contributed to
slowing vaccination rates across the
country as part of a new set of policies
aimed at cutting down on anti-vaccine
content on the google owned site youtube
will ban any videos
that claim that commonly used vaccines
approved by health authorities are
ineffective or dangerous
the company previously blocked videos
that made those claims about coronavirus
vaccines but not ones for other vaccines
like those for measles or chickenpox
so now they're extending it to all
vaccines
and you cannot claim that the vaccine is
ineffective
of course the problem there is well what
do you mean
by ineffective
fauchi himself as we as we talked about
in the opening says that now you need a
booster shot
which would seem to indicate if you need
a third shot six months after you got
your first dose
your first complete dose
of two shots
that would seem really to suggest
that there is a certain lack of
effectiveness
in the in the first complete dose
if it's totally effective then you
wouldn't need another one
and
we're also told all the time that even
if you have the vaccine you should still
be wearing a mask and all of that
why do we need to do that if a vaccine
is totally effective
is does this does this count as
anti-vaccine messaging
or is it
is it anti-vaccine messaging when they
say it or only only if someone like me
says it
what i'm saying right now is this
anti-vaxx content i have no idea but
that's that's the way that's the point
that's how this is set up
uh we're not supposed to know exactly
because then it frees them up to just
decide what voices they want to get rid
of kind of arbitrarily
you know what apparently didn't count as
anti-vaxx content um back in november
in october
when and let's go back
through memory lane here
this was not anti-vax content when
democrats were on tv saying stuff like
this watch
as you know president trump has promised
a coronavirus vaccine by the end of the
year or maybe sooner would you trust
that vaccine
no i would not trust his word i would
trust the word of public health experts
and scientists but not donald trump
first of all
i don't trust the president on vaccines
i think it's going to be a very
skeptical american public about taking
the vaccine and they should be he will
push anything to get reelected don't
fall for it and by the way i will take
the vaccine after ivanka takes it you
would be hesitant
to receive the vaccine if it were
approved by the end of the year
i'm gonna yes i would be hesitant i mean
if
doctors and scientists like dr fauci are
taking that vaccine of course i will
take the vaccine but we also know that
we can't trust the president
and take his word i trust vaccines
i trust scientists but i don't trust
donald trump
and at this moment the american people
can't either i believe all across the
country you're going to need someone
other than this fda
and this cdc saying it's safe
these people
every time i i can't say i'm not shocked
by it
but in a way every time i go back and i
watch a clip like that
you could almost be shocked
by the the how
soulless and fraudulent these people are
it is interesting to imagine an
alternative history where donald trump
uh is still in the in the white house
serving a second term
where would the vaccine conversation be
right now
you know
we could be
in a totally different universe
potentially
because all the way up to joe biden they
were making it very clear that as long
as as long as donald trump is in the
white house
they are anti-vaxx
everything you just i mean you you heard
them saying there
direct quotes i wouldn't trust the
vaccine if if joe if donald trump is in
the white house
and you can't all the stuff they said
there i couldn't if i said that right
now about joe biden i'm done on youtube
i'm off
and on every other social media platform
so what kind of alternative reality
would we be living in if donald trump is
still in the white house
well here's one thing we know it
wouldn't be an entirely alternative
universe
because say what you want about the
anti-vaxxers on the right
um and by that i mean and here i'm
referring to you know
actual anti-vaxx i mean this is there
are people who are actually against
vaccines in general
um and then there are people who are
against the kobe vaccine in general they
don't they don't want a part of it they
don't think anyone should take it
you know i think that both of those both
of those points of view could accurately
be described as anti-vaxx the problem is
now we've broadened that category to
include anyone who is anything less than
religious in their fervent you know
support of vaccination
but anyway the people that that might be
on the right who might be accurately
described as uh as anti-vaxx
uh
are consistent in that
because they were saying that back when
donald trump is in office
and and
those who are are trump fans i mean the
fact is that this is this is one of
trump's great achievements is that he
got this vaccine out there
and yet there are people or big trump
fans
and still take a very skeptical approach
attitude towards the vaccine
so that that's consistency at least
we can't say that if donald trump is
still in office all of the quote-unquote
anti-vaxxers on the right would be
majorly in favor of the vaccine while
the pro-vaccine people on the left will
be against it
i think the pro-vaccine people on the
left would be against it but the people
on the right would probably still be
where they are now
because they've shown that they're not
they're not um
coming to these conclusions based on
who happens to be in office
all right uh here's a just a headline
from and i got to call this out when i
see it i got to call this kind of hate
out this hate and misinformation
this is from the daily beast this is our
headline
it says right wing podcaster fakes
address just to go on anti-trans rant at
school board
says the daily wire star troll
immediately ran to fox news to brag
about quote outsmarting the loudoun
county school board
i i i do appreciate by the way i do
appreciate there at least being given
the title of star troll daily wire uh
but i do also have to humbly decline
that title because i think we are we're
a crew of trolls very proudly and i'm
i'm one but one member of a team of
trolls but faked my address
this again my trans virginian identity
continues to be marginalized by the
media
though i will also mention since we're
on the topic that uh you know i was
talking about it with my wife last night
and i i think i'm ready to announce this
um
that uh we we are con we are considering
moving back to tennessee um
it's been it's been a long journey here
in virginia
and i've really come to to know and love
these people here in virginia
but i still i still also feel this this
deep connection to tennessee so this is
this is a conversation that's ongoing uh
in my family you know i'm saying to my
wife look i think we should just
get all the kids together we should we
should continue to live in this ladies
basement in loudoun county
and she has an alternative viewpoint so
we're going back and forth on that and
maybe more to come on that in the future
but let's get now to reading the
comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this one is uh i actually lied because
this is not a comment on youtube this is
just a tweet someone sent to me but i
had to read it it says my son's college
music school is doing a full concert
honoring a composer who is retiring from
the college
he's not invited because he's not
vaccinated he can't be vaccinated
because of his medical condition i
thought masks worked shameful for them
to treat him that way
so that they're doing the concert for
him in his honor and he's not allowed to
come
my god
we
just as i'm worried about how people
have been conditioned to uh to enjoy
wearing masks
which is which is like an objectively
unenjoyable experience you shouldn't
you really shouldn't be comfortable
wearing that thing across your face
uh
all day
but as people have gotten comfortable
with that they've we've also just gotten
used to treating people
like garbage
and that is by design when you when you
create these these
these two tribes these two categories
the vaxxed and the unvaxed the clean and
the unclean
that's that's by design
and it gives people an excuse to just
you know if you're in that if you're in
that unclean category
there is no treatment for you that is
too harsh you're not worthy of anything
because of because you're refusing to
get vaccinated
um
this is from stanislav says matt walsh
has an acquired taste to put it mildly
i but i find him rarely annoying and
simultaneously utterly intriguing
i'm not just sure i'm not just not sure
what to make of him i detest his shallow
philosophies and medieval zealotry
but i admire the [ __ ] out of his wrapped
conviction and intellectual courage i'll
keep watching for now
well stanislav that was quite a journey
that was that was quite a journey you
took me on there and i'm at the end i'm
not sure
if you hate my guts or if you think or
if you deeply admire me maybe it's a
little bit of both but uh but i'll take
it
as long as you're watching this is from
gibberish says matt would be the guy to
judge in the judgment-free zone at
planet fitness planet fitness is one of
our new sponsors they are a
judgement-free zone they make it very
clear when you go in there
no judgment allowed
uh and uh no i you know the only
the only thing i'll judge you for at the
gym is if you're sitting on the
equipment
and using your phone
which is a which is a an epidemic in
gyms across the country but people
people sit there like they do one set
and then they sit there and they flip
through instagram for 17 minutes and
then they do another set so i'll judge
you for that
and if you don't re
re-rack the weights correctly i'll
probably judge you for that
and if you don't wipe down the equipment
afterwards
and if you're using bad form uh then so
yeah i guess i am judging in the
judgment freeze on i guess you got me
pegged ruthanne says matt you better
show us a picture of that dog you
literally confessed that there's
hundreds of them
uh no i'm not why do you want to see a
picture of my dog why do you need to see
this is not no i'm not the dog has
already taken over my
my house
it's taken my family from me
my kids
and what now you want the dog to be the
star of this show too not gonna happen
uh relaxed straight says matt
technically speaking should a hot dog be
considered a sandwich you know i get
really tired of this debate i you know a
hot dog is obviously a form of a twinkie
which is itself a form of a calzone so
that is the technical answer there well
we were just talking about planet
fitness and uh i plan to fitness is a
new sponsor on the show and listen plant
a fitness is the judgment-free zone even
if i'm not a judgment-free person you at
least get a judgment-free zone over at
planet fitness for just 10 a month you
get tons of cardio uh tons of equipment
that's available to you and with free
fitness training and plenty of room to
move you can go at your own pace and get
back to a routine that really works for
you all for just 10 a month don't wait
join any of our 2000 locations today in
club online or on the app see club for
details and uh there you go you know on
that note we'll get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
in one month i will celebrate my 10th
anniversary with my wife
so far i i must give the marriage
experience five stars out of five
i must because my wife might listen to
this
but also because it's actually true you
know i had the good fortune of marrying
a woman who's care caring faithful
intelligent talented good mother
nurturing joyful loving
she also believes in me and supports me
in my ambitions and that's one of those
qualities in a wife that a man kind of
takes for granted if he has it until he
realizes that lots of men end up in
marriages with women who doubt them cut
them down
belittle their their dreams i've never
had to worry about that with my wife
which is a good thing because as you've
noticed i come up with some pretty weird
schemes sometimes and she's almost
always game for it in fact sometimes
she's the one suggesting
the weird schemes and things i should do
all of these are positive qualities and
on top of it all i must say that my wife
is actually
also really hot which which frankly is
is a huge bonus
now if you're looking at me and
wondering how i managed to land somebody
with all of those
qualities
i have no answer for you i'm just as
perplexed as you are
but it's just one of the reasons why i
thank god every day that i am married
and another reason
is that being married means i'm not
involved in a dating scene today which
is great because that scene is abysmal
in every conceivable way now dating was
not easy a decade ago when i was still
in the game but
it was a walk in the park compared to
the situation today
it's probably never been more difficult
in modern american history anyway for a
single person to find the right match
and that may seem paradoxical because
it's also true that single people have
never had more choices
and that's exactly the problem
case in point a recent article on the
website studyfinds.org about dating apps
and how people use them
and this this is important because
almost all single people today use
dating apps you know
tinder alone has 57 million users that's
just one app overall about 50 of the
population consists of single adults
which is a staggeringly high number as
marriage rates continue to plummet
and about 40 of adults use online dating
so you connect the dots there granted
unfortunately not all of those online
daters are actually single but we can
hopefully assume that the vast majority
are
so what is the actual experience of
using these apps
how do people use them
here's what the article says it says
online dating became a way of life for
millions of singles during the
chronovirus pandemic dating apps like
match.com tinder and okcupid are
responsible for 10
of the long lasting adult relationships
in america
which is actually pretty low considering
how many people use these apps
and as it turns out these daters aren't
wasting time when it comes to choosing
who to swipe right on a recent study
shows that users know within a second
whether or not to express interest in
someone else
so what makes someone choose to make the
move on a profile researchers say it
comes down to judging the book by its
cover
the attractive attractiveness of a
person is primarily what compels another
to swipe right the study finds within a
split second the user determines whether
or not they will
accept a date based on appearance and
even race
now there's nothing new or scandalous
about people choosing mates based first
on appearance appearance is important
and it's not a small or irrelevant
detail yeah they say don't judge a book
by its cover but the thing about a book
is that you don't have to see the cover
while you're reading it you just you
open the cover and that's it
as for someone you're dating or married
to you have to look at that cover every
day
so it's good if you find it appealing my
wife has already outlined has many
wonderful qualities but i never would
have learned about those qualities if i
didn't find her attractive when you
first meet someone you aren't going to
know about their deeper truer selves
and whatever character traits good or
bad may be lying under the surface
those things come out in time doesn't
take a long time but it does take time
initially you're going to be making more
surface level judgments to decide if
it's worth investing that time
so that's not in itself the problem here
the problem is the sheer number of
choices
and how quickly the dating app user has
been conditioned to swipe through them
the problem is also the very act of
swiping i think there's something about
swiping
through just doing this through a series
of human faces that makes the whole
exercise somewhat dystopian and
dehumanizing
yes the cover on the book matters
yes physical attraction matters is
important but these days people are
reduced to just a postage stamp sized
picture on a phone
and potential matches will give them all
of
one second before deciding whether to
relegate them to the junk folder it's
all it's quite degrading
not to mention fruitless
because there are so many people on
these apps and because they're designed
in such a way to encourage these
split-second decisions
all that means is that you have to
browse through an enormous number of
potential matches an article in mashable
a couple of years ago quoting the editor
of a trade publication called global
dating insights says that the average
dating site user has to swipe through 7
500 profiles before having a meaningful
interaction now that's not 7 500 before
finding a girlfriend or boyfriend that's
just the amount of swiping needed to
even have a meaningful human interaction
with a person
and worst of all because these apps
require almost no effort
and no investment
and no energy to use
they only encourage more of the sort of
meandering unseriousness that has
already made the dating scene difficult
and had made it difficult when i was
single a decade ago swiping left and
swiping right becomes more of a game an
end in and of itself
and the people who are on these apps
actually looking for meaningful
interactions for relationship for
commitment have to somehow sort through
this sea of people who only want to hook
up or maybe don't even want that maybe
they want to keep swiping and have no
real deep interest in human
relationships at all
perhaps because they feel that their
porn habit takes care of those needs
it's instructive that even the words
boyfriend girlfriend and dating
aren't as common as they once were
instead of saying you know i'm dating
this person you'll hear people say
things like we're talking
someone said to me recently when
referring to the person that we would
have once called his girlfriend
he said yeah i've been talking to this
girl for six months
six months and you're that's how you
describe it just talking
you haven't even graduated to any kind
of actual
human relationship yet
after six months of dating my wife
at that point i was calling her my
fiance because we were engaged
fear of commitment
passivity
men who will not take the lead in their
relationships
single people kind of meandering along
floating on the tide
dating for no particular reason with no
end goal in mind
too afraid to even call it dating all of
these have been major problems for years
they've been problems increasingly ever
since we came up with the idea of dating
to supplant the idea of courtship
that's really when the the train went
off the rails
the dating apps have only as i said made
all this worse
they've poured fuel on that fire though
i'm not sure that fire is the right
analogy here because that evokes
something that's burning hot with
passion and intensity but passion and
intensity are the opposite of what most
single people encounter
out in the dating world right now
and that is why the dating apps at least
the swiping dating apps today are
cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show
progressives threatened to kill the
bipartisan infrastructure bill unless
moderates go along with their budget
busting plans joe biden sneaks a massive
fine into the democratic budget bill for
businesses that don't force vaccines on
their workers and the biden military
infrastructure finally admits joe
biden's enormous afghanistan screw-up
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen